we have this tweet from the Starbucks
Workers United saying breaking in the
middle of pride month Starbucks bans
Pride decorations and stores across the
United States now according to community
notes and a few other articles there's a
spokesperson saying it is not true they
have no change to their corporate policy
regarding regarding displays for Pride
or any other Heritage Month interesting
we continue to encourage our store
leaders to celebrate with their
communities including U.S pride month in
June I don't believe him why
for one thing you have the actual
workers pointing out they're
experiencing this and they're hearing
from the it's the union saying that
they're hearing from their workers I
think the ideologically motivated
activists are more likely to be outraged
the decorations are coming down and the
corporation is more worried about a
financial backlash to people finding out
their backtracking but there's actually
a much simpler reason I don't believe
the corporation there are videos of
people in Starbucks taking down the
decorations and saying they were told to
take down the decorations according to
Twitter Twitter thread Starbucks Workers
United said for the last two weeks
Starbucks workers have taken a social
media to report the company is no longer
allowing Pride decorations in store this
seems to be the first year the publicly
Pro lgbtq company has taken this kind of
stance taking a cue from Target who
bowed to anti-lgbtq pressure and removed
Pride merchandise corporate and District
management are taking down the pride
decorations that have become an annual
tradition in stores in Union stores
where Starbucks claims they are unable
to make unilateral changes without
bargaining The company took down Pride
decorations and flags anyway ignoring
their own anti-union talking point
Starbucks is powered by many queer
workers but management has failed to
materially support the LGBT community
last October some workers have reported
that their transgender Benefit Plan
changed if Starbucks was a true Ally
they would stand up for us especially
during a time when LGBT people are under
attack a company that cares wouldn't
turn their back true allyship with the
community is negotiating a Union
contract etc etc
well the update to the new Republic
article is that they are denying the
allegations but they're there actually
are videos here we have this video on uh
okay it's gonna make me I'm not gonna I
don't wanna open Tick Tock it's uh they
they did post videos on the article
maybe I can play it this way
there we go
you've got people in Starbucks taking
down Pride Flags so you can see them
taking the flags down you know so when I
see a video like that I'm and and
there's like there's like three or four
others that uh that they played I'm kind
of like yeah I it probably makes sense
that Starbucks is saying take this stuff
down and it may be that all of these
companies are taking major Financial
hits the White House is even condemning
trans activists for their behavior that
we see typical at Pride events it seems
like there is a major shift in the
culture War yeah Corporate America is
scared and I think the elite are
actually starting to become frightened
that they've pushed this on us too
quickly that doesn't mean they've given
up that doesn't mean they've won it just
means that some of them are going to be
a little bit softer with their messaging
for a little while but Starbucks doing
this is quite significant because this
is the place where beautiful people do
important creative things on their
MacBooks and so as the urbanite and uh
brilliant forward-thinking cosmopolitans
who make up their consumer base or or
who are their ideal customers to be less
important to them than the massive
public backlash that they fear might
befall them as occurred uh to Target and
Bud Light is an unbelievably beautiful
thing I mean there is real Market
pressure and I have to say this is not
something I predicted I remember when
people stopped buying Bud Light I was
cautiously optimistic but I was a little
bit worried that it might fall off and
now this is this is trickled all the way
down to Starbucks I mean how wonderful
when you think of liberals you think of
Starbucks exactly that is exactly what
you think of and so that means what the
what the conservatives are doing is
working we're finally doing something
that's working this means we should go
harder keep it up never let down I just
I just kind of think it's much simpler
than that I I I I I don't want to say
it's not working but I think
conservatives are just in the front of
the way of Surfing this this this energy
right Starbucks I'm sorry Target was
already dealing with backlash before
conservatives even brought it up
something changed you know I think it is
I think for the longest time you have
pride parades nobody cares they say I
don't go to those parades I don't care
if you do them then they they have pride
merchandise at stores and they're like
don't know don't care my family doesn't
even know anything about it do your
thing then one day their kid comes home
with a book from school talking about
adult Concepts and showing them graphic
pictures and now they're saying is that
what they've been doing yeah wow and so
then when they walked into a Target they
went no no no no no no I saw those books
now we're seeing the same thing with
Starbucks finally people are saying
you've Stepped On the Line This is the
crazy thing if they just kept it we're
gonna have our celebration and we're
gonna mind our own business nothing
would happen nothing would change but as
soon as they started introducing it to
children now it's taken the whole thing
down but even with the parades and the
celebrations they've like upped the ante
there is rampant degeneracy there are
naked people
um like illegal lewd nudity sex acts Etc
yes especially yeah exactly and in front
of children oftentimes like you know
these are on major city streets and even
if you're not there to go to the pride
parade but if you have to take your kid
to the doctor and you have to walk down
the street that that that's on the
breakout like your kid you they are
forcing your children to interact with
them Non-Stop and I think the parents
have had enough I've had enough well
look the question is do we want to
create a culture where it is safe for
children to be outside in broad daylight
with their parents where they won't be
likely to see anything sexually perverse
or do we want to make this a country
where perverts are free to wear leather
half naked in the streets that's the
question in your average American who is
not necessarily on the right is saying I
prefer a country where children aren't
going to see that when they step outside
you kind of want a balance because a
hundred years ago men weren't allowed to
wear go shirtless good it was illegal uh
because of decency laws to have a no
shirt on you couldn't wear shirts yeah
and it was like no good one shirtless
interesting then take your shirts off I
would rather go back to not being able
to see women's ankles right like
literally not being able to see women's
ankles than what it is now
but you're right you're right no like
let's be real let's be real I I prefer
some uh some good old classical and
traditional liberalism you know people
want to dress the way they dress as long
as not lewd and obscene so you can wear
shorts you can women can wear uh you
know gym shorts and go jogging whatever
they're wearing but you have to cover
your ankles with socks no no but if you
if you're gonna tell me my choice is
between going back to puritanical no
ankles or that video we saw out of West
Hollywood where two adult men performed
a sex acts on each on each other in
front of children I'd be like yeah ban
all of it no ankles yeah like I will
gladly wear two layers in the summer no
child was was ever traumatized or abused
because they couldn't see someone's
ankle right think about this guy as a
woman right do you know how hard it is
for me to even buy a bathing suit that
covers your entire backside like they're
almost non-existent my kids are at
they're like I'm on the beach with my
father my brother my two children and
they are looking at girls butts all day
long like it's like there's nothing
wrong with it the whole like all of
society has gone way off the rails and
they're like oh that's fine I even see
girls in the conservative movement
they're on like religious holiday trips
and they're in thong bathing suits yeah
or at least like you know the ones that
are almost a thong like what are we what
are we what are we doing here I that I
understand like there's a line and it
gets it the line keeps being pushed upon
I don't I don't mind bathing suits the
issue is though you know like Ian you're
just saying it's like Sharia almost look
man we talk about this when it comes to
abortion if my choice is a pro-life
candidate who says there's we should we
should restrict abortion outright I go I
don't know if I agree with that then I
look over to the left and they say
something like we should have people
getting abortions at nine months and I'm
like no we should get rid of that what
are my options my option is literally
just the one who who stops that and that
this is what the left doesn't seem to
understand this is why I think Starbucks
made this move this is why I think these
corporations are making this move
because they're they're right now the
the bifurcation of culture has split
dramatically where the traditional
liberals in this country who are like
we're totally cool with pride flags are
now saying I don't want to have to
explain to my kid why those two adult
men were doing a sex act in public just
get rid of it so now it's like pride
month is out because we you've crossed
the line well I think Lisa you touched
on something very important when you
were discussing having trouble finding a
modest bathing suit which is that as
soon as something becomes normalized it
almost invariably becomes the new status
quo and then that ends up being forced
onto everybody else so it's rarely an
option between uh tyranny and freedom
with these left-wing social causes in
fact with the left that's never the
choice it's almost always you're going
to have reasonable restrictions or you
are actually going to be forced to
support or even engage in licentiousness
and degeneracy I used to wonder about
that how a girl could go outside with a
thong bikini on and not get arrested for
public indecency because I could see her
full butt yeah like well that's just
naked almost right yeah you can't just
put a piece of thread through your butt
crack and pretend like you're not naked
where are the morals amen my father like
I don't want to be with my father on a
beach yeah with with girls and their
butts hanging out like that makes me
uncomfortable don't these people have
any self-respect or or don't they have
any care for their their family and
they're oh it's just gross they were
nude beaches I don't think kids are
supposed to go to those then that's
because you get you know your your skin
sunlight is really healthy for your skin
so you have a backyard everybody's got
some of a backyard that would be ideal
city people not in cities I mean I live
in the city and if I really need to do
then I can make it happen I'm just
saying but I don't need to do that by
the water it's really really healthy all
that sun that uh salt water we're gonna
see a pendulum swing back in the other
direction because it's it's gone too far
there's been there's been tons of
Tolerance there's there's been a ton of
Live and Let Live and that's why at the
beach people are wearing basically
whatever they want but now it's getting
to the point where look the the the I
don't think most people to this day I
think most people still don't care that
women are in bikinis at the beach and
that guys are wearing speedos or
whatever if they do most people still
don't care what happens is you get to
the line where there are people in
parades
the these two adult men this is the
viral video there's also the video of
the guy um shoving his butt up for the
child or the mom laughs like as soon as
that happens the damn breaks yeah the
straw breaks the camel's back and then
regular people regular liberals say
enough this is getting out of hand it's
got to stop yeah it's the sex sacks that
are too much if you went to a beach and
people were in a bikini and uh you know
what you were saying like a dude in a
speedo but they were pretending to get
it on like doggy stuff you know that
would not fly people the cops would be
like you're under arrest for public
indecency you can't simulate sex in
front of kids on the beach like at a
pride parade you can but apparently this
is like a a place in society where
there's been a loophole uh for some
reason Tim's right though but yeah so I
I'm on Instagram and of course their
algorithms favor the things that I like
but I have noticed like really floral
and feminine dresses coming back that
are more modest in nature long right
they're they're they're selling and
they're selling out the racks for like
300 bucks and they're only sold out
right like there's tons of them and I'm
seeing more and more people talk about
wanting to Homestead and I think that
pendulum is starting to swing which is
the only thing that's really given me it
is thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time